[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous et
bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportage sur Public Sénat en étant
ensemble pour
90 minutes comme tous les jours du lundi
au jeudi à 18h et 22h et voici le
sommaire de ceux 19 avril je ne suis pas
indispensable à la CFDT c'est par ces
mots que Laurent Berger a annonçait son
départ de la centrale syndicale après
trois mois un temps de bras de fer
contre la réforme des retraites pourquoi
une telle décision qui pourrait lui
succéder quelles conséquences sur le
calendrier social dans une minute on
répond à ces questions et on fait le
bilan de ces 11 années à la tête du
syndicat réformiste et puis pour notre
second débat c'est ce que l'on appelle
la diplomatie du séisme que je vous
propose d'analyser depuis le tremblement
de terre du 6 février qui a frappé la
Turquie et la Syrie on assiste à un
étrange balai d'officiel à Damas
plusieurs pays arabes semblent dérouler
le tapis rouge au dictateur Bachar
el-Assad au grand désespoir de ce qui
lui résiste depuis 10 ans
c'est une grande trahison de la part des
pays arabes frères et une trahison
mondiale cette normalisation rapide se
fait sans que rien d'échanger au niveau
politique sécuritaire ou à la tête du
régime
là c'est assez voilà pourquoi l'Egypte
la Turquie ou encore hier l'Arabie
Saoudite réhabilite le boucher de Damas
pourra-t-on juger un jour celui qui
porte la mort de 300000 civils sur la
conscience ne ratez pas les explications
de nos invités experts ce sera dans
trois quarts d'heure mais d'abord donc
ce coup de théâtre signé Laurent Berger
il annonce à nos confrères du monde sa
décision de quitter la direction de la
CFDT matthiasarez depuis plus de 10 ans
il incarne la CFDT en 2012 à 44 ans
Laurent Berger jusqu'à leur secrétaire
général adjoint accède à la plus haute
marche du syndicat réformiste suite à la
démission de François cherec d'entrer la
ligne berger éclair ni soutien d'un
gouvernement ni opposant politique
mais contre-pouvoir social autonome et
exigences la CFDT est égal à elle-même
pendant le quinquennat Hollande certains
lui prêtent des habits de ministre du
Travail bis alliés vigilant de
l'exécutif sur les retraites en 2014
Laurent Berger est intransigeant sur la
loi el khomri et obtient quelques recul
du gouvernement comme la suppression des
barèmes des indemnités prud'homales avec
l'élection d'Emmanuel Macron c'est un
interlocuteur plus libéral que trouve
face à lui le leader syndical
en 2019 le CD tiste se dresse vent
debout contre une nouvelle réforme des
retraites portées par Édouard Philippe
avait fixé une ligne rouge c'est une
ligne rouge c'était la réforme
paramétrique le fait qu'il n'y ait pas
de mesure d'âge pour obliger à
travailler plus longtemps deuxièmement
dans cette réforme les mesures sociales
qui sont annoncées sont insuffisantes
notamment sur la question de la
pénibilité je réunis bureau national de
acfdt pour savoir comment on va agir
dans les semaines à venir
une réforme qui mourra dans l’œuf avec
la crise du coronavirus son dernier
combat à la tête de la CFDT restera donc
une réforme des retraites encore une
visant un report de l'âge de départ à 64
ans un combat dans lequel il aura
incarné la plus farouche opposition au
cœur d'une inter syndicale plus soudée
que jamais
complètement réuni on analyse les
conséquences de cette décision on fait
aussi le bilan évidemment des bons
années passées par Laurent Berger la
tête de la CFDT avec Franck Morel
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes avocat
associé chez Flichy Grangé ancien
conseiller social d'Édouard Philippe
vous avez donc côtoyer directement
évidemment Laurent Berger et expert
emploi à l'Institut Montaigne Catherine
tricots bonsoir bienvenue Catherine vous
êtes directrice de la revue regarde
j'accueille également Laurent fragerman
bonsoir bienvenue sociologue historien
spécialiste des mouvements sociaux
chercheurs associés au centre de
recherche sur les liens sociaux de
l'Université Paris cités et Mathieu
croissando bonsoir Mathieu bienvenue
éditorialiste politique franchement on
peut peut-être commencer en disant que
c'est une c'est pas vraiment une
surprise Laurent Berger réélu à la tête
de la CFDT c'était en juin dernier il
avait dit qu'il irait pas au bout de ce
mandat c'est une demi surprise pourquoi
demi surprise parce que comme vous
l'avez rappelé il l'avait annoncé et
lui-même dans l'interview qu'il a
accordé au Monde indique que en son fort
intérieur il pensait partir même plutôt
et que donc il a retardé pour toute une
série de raisons qu'il explicite
ils mettaient en avant une limite de 10
ans plus ou moins deux ans qui était à
peu près le format entre guillemets
habituel en termes de durée de ces de
ces prédécesseurs et donc de ce point de
vue là c'est pas forcément une surprise
c'était quelque chose de prévu ce qui
peut paraître surprenant c'est le fait
qu'il le dise maintenant et si on
cherche un signal peut-être politique
entre guillemets par rapport à cette
annonce maintenant c'est peut-être pour
préparer dès maintenant la séquence qui
va suivre la séquence retraite et puis
il y a peut-être aussi comme élément de
contexte l'élection de Sophie Binet à la
tête de la de la CGT je ne sais pas si
ça je pense pas que ça ait joué dans sa
décision mais c'est un élément aussi en
termes d'environnement qui qui est à
prendre en considération puisque les
deux plus importantes centrales
syndicale de notre pays vont être
dirigés toutes les deux par deux femmes
de la tranche 45 ans parce que a priori
on y reviendra un peu plus tard ce
serait Marily Léon qui succéderait à
celui de Laurent Berger à la tête de de
la CFDT on va citer plusieurs fois à
prendre plusieurs fois des extraits
évidemment de cette interview au Monde
effectivement il nous dit il s'agit
d'une décision mûrement réfléchie
arrêtée dès la fin 2021 ce n'est ni un
coup de tête ni un choix dicté par par
l'actualité Catherine tricot est-ce que
quand même moi quand j'ai quand j'ai
appris cette nouvelle en début
d'après-midi je me suis dit ça acte
quand même la fin du combat contre la
réforme des retraites d'une certaine
façon est-ce que vous le ressentez comme
ça pas du tout
à fait c'était attendu il avait annoncé
en fait il avait envoyé quand même de
manière répétée des signaux pour dire
oui bien sûr quand on interrogeant ah
ben la CFDT c'est encore un homme je
vais m'attendais attendez ça va bientôt
venir et ça sera c'est tout à fait
imminent donc il avait annoncé qu'il
allait céder la place et c'était de la
place à une femme donc je pense que ça
ne dit pas cela par contre je suis
d'accord aussi avec vous que
probablement que le fait que Sophie
Binet arrive à la direction de la sève
de la CGT et que elle crève l'écran donc
il y a
je pense que il a ils ont aussi voulu
mettre en avant une autre femme qui va
pouvoir continuer elle prend toute la
lumière en ce moment donc c'est
intéressant est-ce que vous l'analysez
sous ce spectre là ce prisme là la
concurrence entre la CFDT la et la CGT
alors dans l'interview en question il y
a des passages où il lance quand même
des remarques feutrées à la CGT je
trouve hein c'est pas c'est à la fois
toujours consensuel et polie et puis en
même temps on sent que voilà ce conflit
normal parce que c'est des cultures
syndicales très différentes existent je
suis pas sûr que ça soit vraiment la
raison centrale mais je suis d'accord
sur le fait que celle d'attendre
l'annonce c'est-à-dire il pouvait très
bien attendre trois semaines il le fait
maintenant la CGT annoncée que demain et
la semaine prochaine il lançait leur
propre initiative des journées d'action
donc c'est pas trop le les contours mais
enfin elle veut montrer qu'elle est
suite à son congrès la CGT a clairement
montré par ce fait qu'elle veut qu'elle
entend un carnet quelque chose de plus
combatif et donc il place tout de suite
une espèce une espèce de tuilage je
voudrais rajouter une chose sur le le
délai de 10 ans qui devient une espèce
de règle c'est quand même tout à fait
nouveau c'est à dire qu'elles montmer le
dirigeant historique de la CFDT c'était
17 ans et comme moi quand j'ai fait ma
thèse sur les syndicalistes enseignants
j'avais fait dans les années 1930 aux
années 1970 j'avais fait une carrière
type qui commençait au département
ensuite il y avait une bifurcation soit
vers la mutuelle soit vers la
responsabilité nationale puis ont passé
du syndicat à la Fédération et à la
retraite on continue dans une mutuelle
tout en étant multi engagée et quand
j'ai fait de la sociologie avec la
limitantes d'aujourd'hui ils sont plus
du tout multi engagés ils sont
uniquement dans le syndicat pour
l'essentiel entre eux et au bout ils
sont à peine au bout d'un mandat de 3
ans qu'ils sont en train de réfléchir à
qui va les remplacer c'est-à-dire qu'il
y a un turnover généralisé dans toutes
les organisations syndicales bon il faut
prendre la mesure et ce changement d'air
du temps d'époque on le voit bien avec
cette décision est-ce que c'est aussi le
calendrier politique parce qu'il y a une
accélération du calendrier politique
aussi avec le quinquennat Frank Morel je
sais pas si il faut y faire il voit un
lien pas forcément
des 10 ans c'est pas une nouvelle norme
parce qu'effectivement quand on regarde
notamment les autres organisations
syndicales on est loin des 10 ans mais
c'est une règle qu'il s'était lui-même
fixée effectivement qui n'est qu'une
règle que qu'ils se sont auto auto
prescrit non je pense qu'il y a un point
en revanche qu'il faut souligner c'est
que quand on regarde ce qui s'est passé
dans les deux autres principales
centrales syndicales on constate que les
successions ont jamais été très facile
Sophie Binet est arrivé dans un contexte
n'était pas simple où il y avait deux
candidats qui se sont fait concurrence
et où la candidate la candidate de
Philippe Martinez
pas été simple aussi à la succession de
tirer le pan qui est parti dans les
conditions cloncées du côté de FO les
rappeler il y avait eu un
appartement scandale on avant ensuite il
a été il a été blanchi il faut le
rappeler quand même un Thierry lepend
donc mais au moment voulu ça conduit à
son départ et puis il y a eu la
succession de Jean-Claude maillet à FO
qui n'a pas été simple non plus et on en
est au troisième successeur après le
départ de Jean-Claude Mailly donc il y a
aussi du côté de la CFDT le message qui
peut que ça se passe bien c'est aussi un
enjeu effectivement de la construction
d'une succession tranquille annoncée et
bien organisé et ça ça peut être quelque
chose un message important aussi dans le
départ de Mathieu juste une précision
parce que c'est vrai ce que vous étiez
sur une mère mais il faut rappeler que
quand même que depuis Nicole nota a fait
10 ans et François Cheray qui a fait 10
ans donc une espèce de rythmique qui
s'installe en terme de maximum de
pouvoir à la tête de la centrale
syndicale j'ai l'impression quand même
qu'il y a cette ce problème ce problème
de renouvellement des syndicats qui
impose de ne pas avoir un dirigeant à la
tête de la centrale qui se décroche de
trop de dégénérations les plus actives
et on a quand même un renouvellement du
monde du travail des problématiques
auxquelles sont confrontés les syndicats
et en particulier Laurent Berger avait
quand même souvent argumenté lors de la
bataille sur les retraites que on a une
grande vocation devant nous et qu'il va
falloir mobiliser le monde du travail
pour faire cette transition écologique
et donc les transformations du monde du
travail qui vont l'accompagner donc je
pense que le fait d'avoir quelqu'un qui
n'est pas
usé par la fonction mais aussi qui est
dans la force de l'âge on n'a pas la
même énergie le même à 60 ans qu'à 40
enfin je veux dire voilà et donc je
pense que c'est le raccord avec la
dynamique enfin des des acteurs du monde
du travail je pense c'est une question
importante pour relancer le syndicalisme
alors on va se poser la question
maintenant de l'avenir de Laurent Berger
de ses éventuels ambitions politiques
d'abord en écoute la réaction d'Emmanuel
Macron c'était ce matin à l'occasion de
son déplacement en Alsace
je sais très bien quelle est sa position
et je la respecte très honnêtement c'est
quelqu'un sous différentes conditions
avec qui moi j'ai toujours très bien
travaillé c'est pas un désaccord sur un
sujet qui vaut pour toute une relation
c'est quelqu'un pour qui j'ai du respect
aurais-je dire de l'amitié avec qui j'ai
toujours eu des discussions d'ailleurs
bien au-delà de son de ces simples
fonctions de son mandat sur aussi la vie
il reste de la société qui a joué un
rôle qui joue encore un rôle important
dans un grand syndicat français et donc
c'est plutôt du respect de l'amitié et
après on peut avoir des désaccords
Mathieu dans cette tirade il y a une
phrase qui vous frappe bah oui c'est
quelqu'un pour qui j'ai dû respect
aurais-je dire de l'amitié mais il aura
donc fallu que lamberger décide de tirer
sa révérence pour qu'Emmanuel Macron
salut ce responsable avec lequel il
confie aussi vous avez entendu avoir une
discussion au-delà de sa fonction sur la
vie et sur le reste de la société dont
je t'ai plus on est quand même loin des
perfidis lâchés depuis un mois contre le
syndicaliste auquel le même Emmanuel
Macron reproché d'avoir jamais rien
proposé vous souvenez dans cette réforme
des retraites on a envie de se dire
comme ce fut compliqué entre ces deux-là
alors même qu'on aurait pu imaginer
qu'ils avaient beaucoup de choses pour
s'entendre en tout cas sur le papier au
départ un idéal réformiste de part et
d'autre un même mantra le progrès début
de cheminement intellectuel commencer au
confins de ce qu'on appelait autrefois
la deuxième gauche pour les deux alors
Emmanuel Macron son écarté et bien vite
mais c'est quand même là soi-disant
qu'il est né mais voilà enfin là où
Laurent Berger qui fait de la CFDT qui a
fait de la CFDT le 1er syndicat du pays
il faut le rappeler envisager son rôle
de corps intermédiaire au sens large
pour faire avancer la société bien
Emmanuel Macron lui a toujours vu les
syndicats légitimes mais sur le terrain
dans les entreprises et pas pour se
mêler des affaires du pays et après son
érection
de la République n'a jamais su faire du
syndicaliste un partenaire en tout cas
de lamberger ça faisait pas empêché de
s'entendre sur certains points comme sur
la réforme avortée portée par Édouard
Philippe de la retraite par point
attention sans les mesures paramétriques
là il n'était mais ils se sont opposés
souvent que ce soit sur les ordonnances
travail que ce soit sur l'accueil des
migrants que ce soit évidemment là sur
le report de l'âge légal évidemment à 64
ans est-ce que le départ de Laurent
Berger ça peut être une bonne nouvelle
quand même Macron à première vue oui lui
qui veut passer une nouvelle phase ne
peut que se féliciter d'asseoir autour
de la table de nouveaux visages d'une
certaine façon avec lesquelles il y a
pas de passif personnel Laurent Berger
était devenu le visage de l'opposition à
la réforme des retraites depuis le
départ de son homologue de la CGT
Philippe Martinez il était à la fois
incontournable et encombrant pour le
pouvoir en perdant en leur en berger
d'une certaine façon Emmanuel Macron
perd son meilleur adversaire toutefois
son départ ne change a priori rien à la
ligne de la CFDT si c'est Maryse on qui
le remplace et puis ça ne résoudra
évidemment pas à lui seul ce départ la
crise sociale et politique qui a éclaté
dans le pays depuis trois mois d'autant
que dans la majorité nombreux sont ceux
qui soupçonnent le syndicalisme de ne
pas avoir dit son dernier gros justement
à ses ambitions politiques dont je
parlais tout à l'heure ça veut dire
qu'il y a au sein de la majorité un
certain nombre de gens qui redoutent se
lance en politique en tout cas c'est la
petite musique qui faisait courir depuis
plusieurs mois sans doute parce que
certains de redoutent sans doute parce
que certains cherchent surtout à le
décrédibiliser on entendait le patron de
la CFDT berger il a un ascendant un
agenda personnel il vise 2027 il roule
pour lui ça c'est ce qu'on va répéter
dans le camp présidentiel Laurent Berger
lui s'en est toujours défendu il aurait
dit aujourd'hui dans le monde ça sera ni
2027 ni 2032 même dit-il de sous forme
de boutade je ne m'engagerai pas en
politique Martel till avant toutefois
quand même de lâcher si certains croient
que je vais me taire c'est une erreur
comme il y a d'autres à bon entendeur si
Mathieu Catherine tricot il s'en défend
je le rappelle Laurent Berger de Mathieu
vient de le dire de tout ambition
politique est-ce qu'il pourrait quand
même fédérer la gauche social-démocrate
non vous y croyez à ça ça c'est possible
mais soutenir s'engager en politique ça
dépend ce qu'on veut dire c'est
s'engager au sens de se présenter à
l'élection présidentielle je pense que
ça c'est absolument impensable je pense
qu'il y a aucun d'exemple qui est
fonctionné en France de quelqu'un qui
passe du social vers le politique ce
sont
certaine manière quand même des espaces
qui sont relativement étanches quand je
sais pas j'osais Beauvais par exemple
qui était un syndicaliste extrêmement
populaire mais c'est fracassé quand il
est allé à l'élection présidentielle
alors qu'il était porté d'une certaine
manière par le nom de gauche au
référendum européen il était très
populaire comment patron
dans le champ agricole je pense c'est un
peu différent c'est possible
mais je ne crois je ne le vois pas
partisan et je ne le vois pas même à un
niveau élevé sur le plan électif mais
par contre par exemple la Fondation Jean
Jaurès pourrait tout à fait l'accueillir
enfin je veux dire c'est une manière
quand même de plaisir de faire de la
politique et sur le débat politique mais
je voudrais vous entendre enfin
l'Allemagne sur quelque chose que
Mathieu est ok la CFDT c'est un syndicat
qui d'une certaine façon un projet
politique et l'assume absolument c'est
très particulier donc effectivement la
tradition de la CFDT c'est pas que un
leader issu de Serrant se présente aux
élections c'est que le syndicat en tant
qu'organisation un projet politique
assumé il l'a rappelé plusieurs fois en
disant Emmanuel Macron ne comprend rien
à notre histoire et nous dénit le droit
de faire de la politique on en a
toujours fait et on l'a vu notamment le
moment le plus important c'est les
années 70 un soutiennent la deuxième
gauche Michel Rocard etc donc il y a
toute cette histoire très ancienne où
ils ont toujours pensé qu'en tant que
syndicat ils avaient un rôle à jouer en
général dans le champ de la gauche alors
après avec le recentrage ils ont gardé
ce rôle politique mais en essayant de se
conformer quand même à la demande des
salariés parce qu'on a demandé salarié
unanime c'est que les syndicats ne se
mêlent pas de politique partisanes ça
c'est très important tous les sondages
le monde toutes les enquêtes de terrain
les salariés distinctes très clairement
voilà l'environnement c'est tel type
d'association la politique c'est des
parties et des syndicats c'est le social
donc évidemment qu'il y a des
circulations très importantes entre ces
sphères mais c'est quand même dangereux
pour l'organisation si son ex secrétaire
général se présente qui dans les deux
cas d'ailleurs s'il était élu ce sera un
problème parce qu'il risque de décevoir
et si les battu ça peut aussi poser
problème donc je suis pas convaincu de
ce point de vue là enfin cela dit je
pense qu'il y a un espace pour moi pour
la prochaine élection présidentielle
pour pour lui moi je l'écarte pas en
tant qu'espace politique je pense qu'il
en a mais c'est compliqué vous lui voyez
quel avenir politique effectivement je
rejoins tout ce qui a été dit
précédemment mais je voudrais peut-être
verser à la réflexion quelques éléments
qui expliquent pourquoi cette question
se pose de manière lancinante et lui
proposer de manière lancinante il y a
d'abord effectivement vous l'avez
rappelé le positionnement particulier de
la CFDT sur les sujets qui dépassent
largement le champ stricto-sensude ce
que l'on range habituellement dans le
champ du social c'est-à-dire les
questions de travail d'emploi et donc
beaucoup plus large que ces questions-là
et donc amenant à se positionner sur un
champ plus politique plus sociétal avec
notamment la proposition qui avait été
faite avec des associations du pacte du
pouvoir de vivre qui va bien au-delà des
seuls question de travailler d'emploi et
des questions sociales et donc se
positionnement là très très large peut
amener du coup un certain nombre
d'interrogations sur le thème bah tiens
vous allez sur des sujets qui sont pas
dans le pré carré habituel de la
négociation collective et puis
deuxièmement il y a peut-être d'une
certaine manière compte tenu de
l'évolution du rapport de force des
forces politiques depuis les dernières
années et notamment depuis l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron un vide du centre
gauche et de du besoin de de
personnification d'une certaine manière
qui qui va chercher qui va se qui
cherchent à s'incarner
et du coup voilà un besoin d'incarnation
qui est exprimé sous forme de
questionnement en direction de ce qui
pourrait le faire changer d'avis parce
que là il nous dit hein on va revoir la
citation je ne sais plus comment il faut
le dire je ne m'engagerai pas en
politique quoi c'est dur à dire parce
que comme vous l'avez dit tout à fait de
circonstances et effectivement en
politique il faut jamais dire fontaine
je ne boirai pas de ton eau il y a
beaucoup d'exemples effectivement de
personnes qui ont affirmé avec beaucoup
de sincérité d'ailleurs c'est pas une
question de de non sincérité avec
beaucoup de sincérité une position à un
moment donné qui peuvent évoluer en
fonction des circonstances c'est tout de
même assez peu probable quand même il
faut bien le il faut bien le dire un
exemple qui est réussi
le passage de par exemple même les ce
qu'on appelle les ministres de la
société civile en général font pas quand
même des résultats merveilleux c'est le
passage encore une fois rentré dans le
haut de la politique c'est quand même un
passage difficile qui demande de la
pratique de l'apprentissage les codes
mais c'est pas artificiel c'est que
c'est vraiment comprendre ce que c'est
que la pâte politique
ça se demande d'être formé et je pense
que c'est autre chose que d'être un
leader syndical ou d'être un deuxième
gauche c'est que quand il veut pas y
aller ils vont pas
jactolor souvenez-vous le renoncement
tentative de Michel Rocard infructueuse
c'est pas une c'est pas une c'est pas un
système de culture où on prend le
pouvoir d'acharner c'est plutôt un
laboratoire d'idées pour transformer la
société c'est un peu différent je vois
il y a encore plein de thèmes abordés
mais j'aurais quand même qu'on discute
un peu de la personnalité Laurent Berger
vous avez vous êtes replongé dans sa
biographie il y a quelques temps
qu'est-ce qui vous a frappé ce qui me
fera vraiment c'est qu'il commence en
fait sa formation militante par la job
alors déjà c'est les autres j'y viens
tout de suite mais déjà des origines
très populaires donc ça effectivement du
point de vue du personnel politique
c'est de plus en plus rare le père
ouvrier la mère auxiliaire depuis
et donc il est responsable de la
Jeunesse ouvrière chrétienne donc c'est
une organisation liée à l'église c'est
vraiment le catholicisme social incarné
dans l'époque où il a dirigé j'avais été
un de leurs congrès il s'appelle pas ça
congrès j'avais des frappé par leur
compte leur messe avec la musique de
Pink Floyd c'était très c'était
intéressant et il y a un côté
participatif éducation populaire
mouvement social très ancré et je trouve
qu'il en reste quelque chose alors soit
c'est un excellent acteur mais quand il
dit par exemple il est choqué par le
refus du dialogue social par Emmanuel
Macron il me semble sincère vraiment
l'honnête homme qui ne comprend pas
qu'on puisse pas discuter autour de la
table et trouver un agrément un
gentleman agrement et il y a vraiment du
point de vue après alors il incarne une
organisation c'est une culture
catholique sociale très clairement on
retrouve tous les éléments du
catholicisme social et notamment ce côté
vraiment on peut être dur dans
l'encyclique Eram novarum qui est la
base du catholicisme social on est dur
sur les riches qui ne partagent pas mais
on veut la Concorde on veut la
collaboration entre tout le monde et
donc de ce point de vue là il est à mon
avis à toute la CFDT en colère et je
finirai là-dessus parce que c'est on a
quelquefois un peu feuilletonné quand
même sur Laurent Berger etc il y a une
organisation derrière et lui on le
rappelle il le rappelle et il dit il
faut quand même bien voir que depuis 5
ans toute la CFDT est en colère par
rapport à la politique monsieur Macron
c'est pas seulement lui c'est toute une
organisation c'est tous les militants
les cadres qui se trouvent complètement
à contre-courant de cette évolution je
rajouterais une toute dernière phrase
dans l'interview et il dit c'est un don
d'avoir été secrétaire général c'est
typiquement la culture catholique il a
pas rajouté don du ciel mais c'était ça
c'est intéressant Franck Morel la
rupture c'est la fin de la première
réforme des retraites d'une certaine
façon vous l'avez vécu de l'intérieur
c'est la fin on peut le dater aussi de
la négociation sur l'assurance chômage
qui a été enfin de la fin de la
négociation sur l'assurance chômage qui
sont à peu près dans la même période
c'est-à-dire en 2018 2019 on va dire
plutôt début de l'année 2019 non si on
regarde effectivement les la durée du
mandat de Laurent Berger ce qui est ce
qui est assez marquant c'est que les
succès les plus importants qu'il a
obtenu à la tête de la CFDT c'est moi je
dirais c'est d'abord la négociation au
tout début de son mandat sur le marché
du travail avec l'accord de janvier 2013
et l'équilibre qui avait été trouvé un
grand accord national interprofessionnel
un équilibre trouvé entre un
assouplissement des règles de
licenciement collectif d'un côté et une
généralisation de la complémentaire
santé pour les salariés de l'autre et
puis évidemment vous l'avez situe tout à
l'heure le fait que la CFDT est devenu
pendant son mandat
le premier syndicat de France moi je me
souviens pour les salariés du privé en
tout cas puisque il y avait il y avait
un débat au moment où ça s'est passé sur
la compilation privée publique où
c'était les chiffres qui vont s'afficher
sur effectivement la CFDT premier
syndicat de France je vous laisse
continuer oui moi j'ai souvenir de du
moment qui est très symbolique ou lors
d'une réunion à Matignon ce n'est plus
Geoffroy route des yeux et Philippe
Martinez qui était côte à côte mais on a
interverti les sièges pour mettre côte à
côte je crois roue de Baisieux d'un côté
et Laurent Berger de l'autre qui était
la marque symbolique du changement du
tiercé de tête hiérarchique
effectivement entre les organisations
syndicales alors c'est un point qu'il
faut noter après il faut le nuancer
aussi parce que les la progression de la
CFDT en nombre de voix a été quand même
relativement limité et c'est surtout en
réalité la baisse de la de la CGT qui a
fait que la hiérarchie le tiercé tête a
changé c'est voilà donc c'est c'est
surtout les deux plus petits en réalité
qui ont beaucoup progressé la CFE-CGC
qui est de tous les syndicats celui qui
a le plus progressé et puis un petit peu
la CFE-CGC allez on va voir tout de
suite comment réagit comment réagit les
sénateurs quand un Calmet juste là dans
les coulisses de sciences publiques
bonsoir Quentin bienvenue à vous vous
êtes allés à la rencontre de plusieurs
sénateurs aujourd'hui pour nous dire
comment voilà ils ont appris et reçu la
nouvelle de ce de cette de ce départ de
la direction de la CFDT de lamberger oui
c'est ça et puis ça fait un tour
d'horizon aussi politique et vous allez
voir qu'il reprenne beaucoup d'éléments
de ce que vous évoquez en plateau et
effectivement les communistes par
exemple qui s'allument l'évolution à la
tête des deux principaux syndicats en
France on l'a dit avec l'arrivée de
Sophie Binet qui va prendre le scrapage
général de la CGT et donc maintenant
Marylise Léon qui va et bien prendre la
suite à partir du 21 juin de Laurent
Berger il dit voilà les communistes une
évolution aussi du marché du travail et
de la place des femmes dans le monde du
travail écoutez parce qu'elle savait le
délire renouvellement la CFDT il y en a
eu un à la CGT important et quand je
vois les premiers pas que fait Sophie
Binet c'est plutôt encourageant voilà il
y a un renouveau du syndicalisme il y a
une dynamique il y a des nouveaux
visages et c'est bien que ça fasse
événement qu'on mette à la Une des
syndicalistes vous voyez et en plus
qu'on mette des femmes
les communistes qui se réjouissent ces
syndicalistes à la Une effectivement des
journaux le centriste Hervé Marseille
lui il retient plutôt la notion de
modération de Laurent Berger ce
syndicaliste réformiste écouté récé le
chef de fil des centrist à gauche est
devenue très radicale avec la nupesse et
il incarne quelque part ce qui manque
aujourd'hui cette gauche sociale
démocrate ce courant modéré qui apporte
beaucoup
traditionnellement à la vie du pays
Marseille qui voit en leur hébergé un
homme de qualité de dialogue qui je cite
peut apporter beaucoup à la vie publique
et on voyait les sénateurs en salle des
conférences qui débattaient donc des
ambitions politiques de leur engher un
futur possible en politique est-ce
possible écouter l'analyse du LR Jérôme
Bacher
ah mais il est incarne une figure
effectivement qui pourrait faire de la
politique je ne crois pas que ce soit
moderne aujourd'hui de mêler
syndicalisme et politique d'ailleurs la
CGT SUD Lutte Ouvrière etc tous ces
grands mouvements qui avaient des
traditions fortes entre les syndicats et
les partis politiques aujourd'hui on
voit bien qu'il y a une déconnexion
entre les uns et les autres je ne sais
pas si ça trouve une base électorale
mais pourquoi pas ça sera à lui de dire
on a vu d'autres sortir de nulle part et
être président de la République voilà
effectivement on en a vu d'autres Thomas
en l'occurrence pour leur panne
ambiguïté puisqu'il a dit qu'il serait
pas qu'on les a en 2027 évidemment il
l'a redit dans l'intervé au monde merci
quant à Catherine tricot ça ça doit vous
surprendre mais vous avez un sénateur LR
qui dit à peu près la même chose que que
vous sur ce c'est pas moderne de mêler
syndicalisme et politique
j'ai dit qu'on peut pas devenir
non au contraire moi je pense que je
pense que
d'une candidature présidentielle d'été à
nourri avec le projet politique je pense
à très intéressant et très moderne et
d'ailleurs ça a fait bouger la CGT c'est
à dire que quand Laurent Berger a fait
ce pacte notamment avec Nicolas Hulot et
ben Martinez lui a fait un pacte avec
Greenpeace et attaque donc c'est à dire
que cette idée que les syndicats doivent
se désenclaver ne pas rester sur le
champ du social strict mais être sur le
champ de la société c'est quand même une
tendance qu'on prie l'un et l'autre des
deux principaux syndicats ce qui est sûr
c'est que c'est une nouvelle mission
avant le lien entre politique et
syndicats faisaient du syndicat de la
courroie de transmission politique
aujourd'hui les syndicats qui sont dans
l'ordre désorbites politiques joue
plutôt le rôle d'aiguillon de courroie
de transmission et pour la CFDT ça a
toujours été ça faut rappeler que bon
maire c'était le PSU que quand la CFDT
se lance elle est déconfessionnelle
puisque elle éclate avec la CFD la CFTC
et que le mot d'ordre de la CFDT des
années 70 au début ces trois mots c'est
nationalisation planification
autogestion donc on est vraiment sur un
programme une approche qui le virage de
recentrage vous en avez parlé tout à
l'heure il a été effectué par edmond
Maire qui a changé d'avis en cours de
route et qui ce qui correspond aussi à
l'élargissement d'audience d'une
certaine façon de la CFDT c'est la place
du réformisme au-delà du fait que la
CFDT soit le premier syndicat de France
ça dit aussi quelque chose des deux
approches historiques du cdclisme en
France que vous connaissez le
syndicalisme révolutionnaire ou ça qui
est réformiste c'est plutôt celui-là
aujourd'hui qui est en termes de de
en tout cas a pris la première place
mais c'est intéressant de noter que
c'est celui-là avec le fait que dans
l'histoire les choses n'ont pas été
toujours aussi simple dans ce classement
entre syndicalisme révolutionnaire et
syndicalisme réformiste puisque je
rappelle que André Bergeron par exemple
à l'époque était le patron de FO
passait pour être le patron de la
centrale à l'époque qui était présenté
comme la centrale réformiste
l'interlocuteur privilégié etc etc et
progressivement la CFDT a pris la place
dans ce dans ce registre là on va dire
de FO du FO d'André Bergeron le
successeur de Bergeron
Marc Blondel ne s'inscrivant pas dans ce
cadre-là on se souvient des des tirades
de marque Blondel contre à l'époque la
réforme de 1995 de la Juppé c'était
quand même assez assez costaud on va
dire c'est tirades et donc effectivement
c'est la CFDT qui a pris ce qui a pris
ce relais mais il y a aussi un
changement d'époque on a noté un point
extrêmement symbolique qui me font
rappeler c'est par exemple le fait que
Sophie Binet la nouvelle patronne de la
CGT n'est pas membre du Parti communiste
et c'est quand même une première dans
l'histoire de la CGT puisque longtemps
les patrons de la CGT avaient un lien
privilégié avec le PC ce qui n'est pas
le cas du tout de ce féminin puisque au
contraire même elle a elle a fait un
bout de chemin plutôt du côté du Parti
socialiste donc c'est effectivement un
point d'évolution de la parole juste
après on parle de Marylise Léon donc
voilà un ajout rapide là-dessus parce
qu'il y a encore une équipe à la CGT et
dans cette équipe le numéro 2
l'administrateur c'est Philippe Brun de
cheminot qui appelait à voter pour
Roussel donc à mon avis sur la place des
communistes dans la CGT il faut être
clair
une tension
la terre n'est pas n'est pas si simple
que ça surtout qu'elle a pas été élu sur
une ligne en plus
compliqué une histoire parce qu'elle est
quand même celle qui a porté l'alliance
avec Greenpeace attaque elle est une
militante
parce que c'est important pour la suite
y compris pour là c'est-à-dire que ce
qui est frappant c'est que si on regarde
électoralement la CFDT est le premier en
terme de militants pour moi c'est quand
même encore toujours la CGT c'est à dire
que dans la dans les années qui viennent
la grande question c'est est-ce que les
propos de Sophie business sur la
syndicalisation sur le fait d'un peu
améliorer les structures de la CGT qui
sont une catastrophe absolue est-ce que
si ça ça se fait il y a une possibilité
pour la CGT de gagner du terrain de
récupérer le terrain perdu d'un autre si
vous regardez électoralement vous rendez
compte que dans le privé les syndicats
d'irréformis sont ultra majoritaires
plus de 60% des voix si on additionne la
CFDT la cfdtc l'une etc l'une ça etc et
en sachant que il faut selon les
endroits et d'un côté ou de l'eau donc
on les classe pas donc on est dans un
situation où pour être rapide vous avez
d'un côté la CGT qui s'est affaibli mais
qui à l'avantage d'avoir à ses côtés Sud
qui est très faible 2% de 3% dans le
privé juste au-dessus de la limite de la
représentativité dans le public 5% la
FSU qui n'a pas l'intention de se
développer au-delà de ces zones de force
fonction publique d'État fonction
publique territoriale donc la CGT peut
facilement embarquer ces deux alliances
qui peuvent être encombrants mais ils
peuvent faire bloc tandis que la CFDT
certes et la première mais la CFTC est
largement à 10% le seul État 8%
et pas loin de la représentativité ils
sont est en train de l'obtenir allez on
parle de Marylise Léon tout de suite
puisque effectivement on l'a on l'a dit
plusieurs fois et Quentin nous le
rappelait c'est elle qui est appelée a
priori un succédé à Laurent Berger alors
je vous propose peut-être que vous ne
connaissez pas son son visage ou que
vous n'avez pas retenu ses interventions
là pendant ces trois mois de bagarre de
bras de fer contre la réforme des
retraites écoutez là c'était au
lendemain l'interview de du président de
la République dans les 13 heures de TF1
et France 2 elle réagissait au pic
présidentiel contre Laurent Berger
contre la CFDT c'est parce que j'appelle
un dialogue voilà c'est des petites
phrases
qui donnent à avoir un agacement qui qui
est absolument malvenu dans la période
quand on est responsable politique voilà
on ne s'attaque pas à une organisation
syndicale ou à ce stratégie générale le
patient aussi
aussi directe Franck Morel j'imagine que
vous avez eu l'occasion de travailler de
rencontrer plusieurs fois Maryse Léon
quelle négociatrice est-elle c'est une
négociatrice tenace puisqu'elle était
par exemple la cicatrices de la CFDT
dans la négo-assurance chômage
et donc elle a elle a défendu la ligne
de la CFDT durant cette négociation
c'est quelqu'un de très ouvert à la
discussion c'est quelqu'un d'un contact
extrêmement constructif agréable moi
j'ai toujours eu plaisir à échanger avec
Marylise Léon j'avais que j'ai eu
souvent au téléphone pendant la période
où je conseiller Édouard Philippe donc
je pense qu'effectivement elle va elle a
toute sa je dirais elle a toute
légitimité pour prendre la suite de leur
en berger je pense qu'elle le fera
qu'elle le fera avec beaucoup de talents
après elle le fera dans le cadre du
mandat qui était celui de lamberger et
qui reste qui restera le sien dans ce
cadre là donc il faut pas s'attendre
c'est pas parce que elle a un abord je
dirais ouvert avenant constructif il
faut pas s'attendre à un changement de
ligne de la CFDT du jour au lendemain
vers quelque chose de d'encore plus
réformiste il faut s'entendre d'une
certaine manière une continuité après ça
fait toujours du bien de changer les
têtes au-delà d'une certaine d'un
certain délai dans dans des contextes
comme celui que l'on connaît et donc ça
fera sans doute du bien effectivement
d'avoir deux femmes
plutôt jeunes plutôt expérimenté et à la
fois constructive et ouverte à la tête
des deux principales centrales
syndicales et l'avenir dira qu'elle en
sera l'impact sur la ligne de ces deux
organisations syndicales c'est un peu
tôt aujourd'hui pour le dire je le
disais tout à l'heure Sophie Binet n'a
pas été élu sur une ligne et quant à
Marie Lise Léon et bien la ligne c'est
plutôt la continuité de celle sur la
base de laquelle Laurent Berger a été
élu vous allez nous expliquer si c'est
sûr quel succède à la grande berger
comment ça va se passer mais j'aurais
quand même vous entendre vous l'avez
évoqué rapidement tout à l'heure
Catherine tricot le enfin voilà il y a
c'est un symbole effectivement de femmes
de cadra à la tête des deux principaux
syndicats français bon voilà le notre
société bouge quoi c'est pas mal moi ce
que je c'est que en dehors de cette
question de raccord du syndicat avec le
monde du travail elles ont toutes les
deux quand même un problème sérieux pour
chacune leurs syndicat de façon très
différente la CFDT est confrontée au
problème qu'il n'y a personne pour
négocier c'est un syndicat réformisme
mais il y a personne pour négocier c'est
on leur ferme la porte il y a rien à
négocier et il gagne rien la CGT est un
on peut dire ça sur les trois mois
précédents peut-être pas sur le
trimestre qui s'ouvre peut-être pas son
prénom
il y a une négociation qui s'ouvre
potentiellement sur des six ans qui
viennent de se passer voilà c'est pas
sur les trois derniers mois qu'il y a un
problème de rapport entre le voilà entre
voilà entre du moi je pense qu'il y a
une difficulté pour eux de de trouver un
espace de négociation et de gain de
gagner quelque chose pour l'instant les
syndicats ne font que perdre dans notre
pays depuis 30 ans depuis 1995 où il y a
eu le mieux qu'on ait réussi à faire
dans le monde syndical c'est à empêcher
dégradation des conquêtes positives il
n'y en a pas eu depuis
bah je sais pas François Mitterrand on
va dire alors je pense qu'il y a ce
problème là pour la CFDT c'est d'avoir
d'arriver à gagner des choses positives
et de trouver des interlocuteurs du côté
de la CGT c'est un autre problème c'est
que ils sont plus sur le registre de la
lutte il faut aussi avoir des conquêtes
quand on lutte c'est-à-dire que une va
négocier il faut qu'elle gagne et
l'autre elle veut lutter il faut qu'elle
gagne c'est que l'un et l'autre ce que
je veux dire c'est que les deux
syndicats les deux grands syndicats
français se vendent sont devant des
difficultés qui sont un peu différents
mais quand même de même nature c'est
comment
syndicale depuis 30 ans mais c'est
presque un autre débat je voudrais qu'on
en reste quand même sur ce cette
question de Maryse Leon comment ça va se
passer c'est pas le même schéma qu'elle
a CGT que les choses soient claires ou
peut-être que c'est c'est une élection
et qu'elle risque de la perdre je sais
pas c'est une élection donc il y a
toujours la possibilité d'une surprise
démocratique il y a des vrais trucs des
structures etc il y a pas de souci
après la CFDT a toujours été plus
centralisée que la CGT après en fait
l'image la CGT vient du fait que pendant
très longtemps c'est le parti communiste
qui était qui pouvait placer ses cadres
etc donc qui donnait une structure mais
les statues la pratique de la CGT c'est
le fédéralisme donc chacun fait un peu
ce qu'il veut chez lui à la CFDT les
cotisations mais depuis des décennies
sont prises par directement par le
sommeil et ensuite redistribuer à la
base et quand il y a eu la crise
notamment dans les années 90 80 90 quand
la c'est la direction de la CBT a décidé
de se débarrasser de ce qu'ils
appelaient j'encaspard appeler les
moutons noirs et bien c'était des gens
qui étaient demandés c'est-à-dire vous
êtes permanence syndicale puis du jour
au lendemain la fédération ou la
structure au-dessus je vous dis bah
s'adresse à votre entreprise et dit bah
maintenant vous retournez au travail
sans plus donc il peut y avoir il y a ça
donc ce qui me fait penser qu'il n'y
aura pas de crise je pense que ça va se
passer très tranquillement c'est qu'il
n'y a il y a visiblement du consensus en
interne il y a pas deux lignes qui
s'affrontent on n'est pas dans une
période de en plus ils viennent de
gagner cette première place ils sont
dans une dynamique on n'a pas senti de
contestation interne en tout cas
transparente extérieure sur le enfin qui
soit visible à l'extérieur sur le fait
quand même ils aient décidé de
participer à une action avec la CGT va
parce que comme vous l'avez dit les deux
syndicats ont tordu le bras à leur
pratique depuis des années et on a
travaillé ensemble c'est ça la grande
nouveauté mais on n'a pas vu à la CFDT
de conseils donc je pense que ça va bien
se passer parce que c'est une
organisation disciplinée et qui n'a pas
de débat fort à trancher je voudrais
rappeler aussi un autre élément de
contexte qui est important c'est que le
Medef va changer de tête aussi et le
Medef va changer de tête avant l'été et
donc ça veut dire qu'on va avoir un
contexte d'organisation du dialogue
social dans lequel on aura trois têtes
nouvelles et pas les plus petites entre
guillemets en termes de de d'importance
d'organisation et à côté de ça on a un
contexte qui peut permettre
objectivement
aux partenaires sociaux de reprendre
entre eux d'une certaine manière la main
avec un certain nombre de sujets autour
de l'emploi des seniors autour d'usure
professionnelle autour de ce qui a été
mis en avant autour de ce que le
président a appelé le pacte de vie au
travail et donc dans ce contexte là pour
peu qu'il y a un calendrier qui permette
aux partenaires sociaux de la des 100
jours voilà et donc voilà pour peu que
que ce calendrier puisse permettre
d'organiser de manière efficace la
négociation et je pense que ça sera le
cas parce que tout le monde y a
objectivement intérêt et bien il y a un
rendez-vous important pour ces nouveaux
venus pour ces trois nouveaux venus donc
une opportunité c'est peut-être une
opportunité à saisir Mathieu juste
quelque chose sur lui enfin des femmes
faut quand même rappeler que la CFDT fut
la première organisation a confié son
destin à une femme Nicole nota à une
époque où les parties aucun été dirigées
par une femme les syndicats aucun appart
peut-être le SNES à l'époque de Monique
Veya aucun été dirigé voilà n'était
dirigé par les femmes donc c'est cette
démarche féminisante en tout cas elle a
eu lieu au début des années 90 à la cfdc
photos de l'Inter syndicale on voit des
femmes quand on voit les photos des
parties de gauche on voit pas de femme
donc on dort maintenant de la
responsable de l'Europe Écologie Les
Verts alors Laurent Berger on a on a vu
que effectivement pendant son mandat son
syndicat était passé premier syndicat de
France il laisse à ses successeurs une
une CFDT en bonne santé en tout cas
c'est ce qu'il affirme dans son
interview au Monde je pense que le 21
juin je laisserai une CFDT qui va bien
elle compte 31000 adhérents de plus en
plus depuis le début de l'année elle a
créé plusieurs centaines de sections
syndicales etc etc reconnu comme une
organisation responsable combative et
constructive Laurent fragile 31000
adhérents de plus donc je comprends bien
depuis le début de l'année donc c'est
vraiment on se dit c'est lié au convoi
contre la réforme des retraites est-ce
que c'est vrai tous les syndicats à
votre connaissance alors moi c'est vrai
pour moi l'enjeu ce sera de les garder
parce qu'en fait il y a un turnover très
fort et donc la grande question c'est
une fois que vous avez des gens qui
adhèrent c'est de les fidéliser euh mais
oui oui je pense que c'est vrai je pense
qu'il y a un élan il y a une image qui a
progressé qui s'amélioré donc les
indicateurs sont plutôt ouverts après il
n'est possible on verra à la fin du
mouvement quand il sera complètement
terminé on verra ce qu'on pense les
salariés mais et donc ce qu'ils sont
déçus ou pas je pense que ce qui est
intéressant c'est que tout le travail de
syndicalisation qui a fait la sévérité
depuis des années d'implantation
notamment mais l'entreprise moyenne du
secteur privé d'entreprise il y a pas de
culture de grève elle a abouti là
pendant le mouvement a complètement mais
il y a une conversion en partie vers des
luttes on a plus de salariés du privé
qui ont manifesté qui ont fait grève et
je pense alors c'est pas lié qu'à la
CFDT évidemment mais ce travail syndical
de terrain peut invisible et bien il a
abouti il est en train de se convertir
dans une nouvelle conflictualité et à
mon avis on parlait du patronat c'est
quelque chose qui va peser dans les
années qui suivent ils ont est-ce que
vous diriez Franck mal que les les
syndicats sortent renforcés de cette
séquence retraite même si finalement ils
ont pas obtenu le le
des retrait de la du prolongement de la
jigue légale je vais y arriver jusqu'à
64 ans si j'utiliserai le verbe
renforcer je dirais qu'ils ont bien
maîtrisé la séquence effectivement
le long terme dira effectivement si le
regard de d'adhésion est un quelque
chose de durable ou pas
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle que les
syndicats maintiennent leur place parce
qu'on a besoin effectivement dans notre
pays et pour faire vivre le dialogue
social de de corps intermédiaire qui ont
une certaine une certaine assise une
certaine puissance il y a quand même des
difficultés structurelles de long terme
qu'il faut qu'il faut rappeler avec un
vieillissement avec une difficulté dans
un certain nombre de cas à trouver des
candidats et donc il y a quand même
malgré tout un certain nombre de
questions qui vont demeurer au
syndicalisme sur les voies et moyens
effectivement de se renouveler on est
alors on peut voir le verre à moitié
vide ou le verre à moitié plein mais on
est sur quelque chose de en termes de
taux de syndicalisation on est sur
quelque chose qui est à peu près
stationnaire depuis une une vingtaine
d'années entre aux alentours de 8% dans
le secteur privé 8 à 10 voilà en
fonction voilà alors selon qu'on compte
le public ou pas selon qu'on compte
seulement le secteur privé effectivement
mais on est sur quelque chose qui est à
peu près stationnaire qui qui a cessé de
baisser qui a qui a longtemps baissé qui
sait plutôt stabilisé et donc le verre à
moitié plein c'est que ça a plutôt cessé
de baisser mais le verre à moitié vide
c'est qu'on reste effectivement sur ce
niveau là et c'est la raison pour
laquelle dernier mot d'ailleurs la
représentativité des syndicats est
fondée sur l'élection et pas sur le
nombre d'adhérents et donc l'enjeu il
est pas seulement de trouver des
adhérents il est aussi de faire vivre
dans les entreprises le processus
électoral merci beaucoup merci à tous et
à bientôt sur Public Sénat